you know the pure existential universe
I mean marchello fechino said man is to
be the measure of all things well this
sounds like old hat in 1990 but in 1480
you know this was such a dizzying notion
that it can hardly be imagined you know
Giordano Bruno went to the stake was
burned at the stake for insisting that
the universe was Infinite in all
directions you know he said no the stars
and planets go on to infinity and they
just said you know this is off-the-wall
only a demon could inspire a thought
like this but the transition that we're
asked to make that was a transition you
see from the certitude of dogma to
secular existentialism the transition
that we're being asked to make is
somewhat similar but to my mind deeper
more challenging more profound it's the
shift from scientific certitude
scientific certitude to a complete
embracing of non closure to actually
begin it's the kind of maturity you know
what we're being asked to do is to grow
up and realize that you know there ain't
no free lunch there aren't always happy
endings not every story ends with the
German Shepherd running in and licking
grandpa's face and everybody laughing
and so forth and so on you know hard
truths and this lack of closure thing I
mean I feel it in myself and I assume
you know that ontogeny recapitulates and
so forth so that you know the struggle
to become a real human being is the
struggle to give up having it actually
make any sense ultimately where I think
it was of all people Robert Frost to
said the secret of a happy life is
learning to enjoy people you don't
approve of well you know there's
something yeah
there's what that means is you're
surrendering to life you're just saying
you know it's bigger than I am I may not
like drag queens but there they are and
I should get used to it I should make
the adjustment this kind of thing in
other words recognizing the complexity
of the situation and science has been
like a long centuries long bender to
exercise precisely exercise precisely
this kind of uncertainty from life and
you know to reduce it all to two atoms
blindly running under the control of
mathematically describable fields of
force the problem is all the
higher-order phenomena sociological
political aesthetic human organizational
got shoved off to one side and just sort
of festered there for a long time while
technology perfected itself mass
production mass media information
transfer but the human dimension lagged
and now there is this tremendous
imbalance between like the technological
descriptive power of the culture and its
moral and ethical power to direct itself
toward any kind of rational goal well
when this happens in a society or even
in a personality you know you can sort
of make a union model of this you get
what's called compensatory phenomena or
at least that's what it used to be
called means eruptions of material from
the unconscious that is organized and
constellated like a mess
like an attention claiming thing in a
person in a personality it ruptures as a
symptom it may be an attention-getting
symptom to then bring other people into
the caregiving loop or something like
that in a society like our own a
scientific society it takes the form of
the irrational the irrational appearing
in strange forms a good example of this
in the past is the birth of Christianity
in the center of the early Middle Roman
Empire where you know the people who
were administering the world at that
time were Romans educated by Greeks who
were epicurean atomists not Platonists
not followers of Heraclitus or
pythagoras or any of the flashy folks
we're into they were democraty and
atomists rationalists materialism would
have been very comfortable in a modern
chemical engineering company and they
they could not conceive that the
irrational could hold any threat to
their world meanwhile they had dark skin
servants in the kitchens and in the
gardens Jews Greeks Phoenicians people
brought from eastern Mediterranean and
among these people specifically the Jews
this rumour began to tear loose about a
Galilean politician who had somehow
tweaked the Romans and then risen from
the dead whoa any Roman administrator
listening to his illiterate cook or
gardener babble out this story would
just you know think these folks is
getting stranger every day
but what was actually happening you know
was a message was being enunciated which
within 50 years would be hammering at
the gate be hammering at the gates of
Rome with all the power of an invading
army